world of warcraft came at in 2004 since
then we've had have a bunch of expansion
packs with a video game burning crusade
let's see if we can do them at Eric Tay
wrath of the lich can ratchet right
through the skin I think Justin have all
the second burning Christopher teacher
say thirty percent not the lychgate
wrath at Cataclysm I think was there
something before cata handle then
Padma's no no cataclysm then Thomas then
drown or yeah you guys it's it's the
Panda and Cataclysm that's really not
i'm pretty sure it's no no no I'm pretty
sure it's panda than cat it cuz I didn't
play penned area and then I played
Cataclysm I go back and play everyone
for like a bit two weeks now I'm like
all right I got my better and we're
going to do it all over again and
because Brian expansion pack lesion is
coming out next year and not a damn
minute too soon it would seem with the
we had a bunch of mine at the top of
Jonna I think there was like 10 million
people playing what's the Dan genetic
thing I got right it does end yeah
that's the problem like they're
announcing this at the worst possible
time like they should have already
announced this because now it sounds
like it's more Bree I mean we know it's
not we know they're working on these
expansions as soon as one is finished
yes but it makes it sound like oh oh now
that we're down to five million we
needed an expansion mmm like and it
makes it more reactionary rather than
like here's a planned thing so what have
they said it's in Legion we've got a
demon hunter new class got new artifact
weapons yes there's a new hero class as
well and so it's not like a regular
class you're gonna take it's more like a
the one in Wrath that one that was added
back in Wrath yeah I'm trying to think
about myself and the love of cosmic
level to orange at night Diego it's
brought up from 100 to 110 and to be a
bunch of our quest I interviewed the
guys ash gamescom and it sounded like
this is almost entirely end game stuff
like they are concentrating on the
endgame how did you go back and played
run over because from what I'm hearing
from my mates you play where the end
game and that was just not log yeah like
the not much rating lots of just going
out and like accumulating resources how
did you feel it finding well I mean
that's it it made it even more of kind
of a mini job where you go in you check
on your your garrison every day like
it's it's fun it's fun in that it keeps
you coming back but it's also the kind
of thing that I can't keep doing like I
just can't invest that much daily time
like I did enjoy like let's run through
that let's level back up and that that's
what legions going to offer as well like
that they're going to be able to start
you out at 100 if you want a new
character like oh cool now i get another
character i can bump up straight to 100
get right into the new content but is
there going to be stuff to do beyond
that how like how long is it kind of
take again to level up to 110 well they
have a brand new area the broken Isles
seems like they're running out of
heretics got pizza no man they just they
just spin it back in time and then you
just reuse it they did that already
amber amber they did that already
[ __ ] I think that was lich king when
they went out the all the sort of
ancient time bending stuff you can do so
what I think they're gonna do eventually
is just tie this world into destiny much
like that is not what destiny star for
content and World of Warcraft is starved
for microtransactions the Destiny the
story the lore they'll come together
they're both Activision Blizzard those
worlds will come together then you have
a first person should I count with this
place yeah that toys to life Activision
game that's come with all their
properties and air Tay is this when was
last time you play well I played Draenor
I I did a little bit of the raid when if
the the very first one I did a couple
bosses it was kind of like old days
again it's just one of those things of
how much time you want to spend to beat
it and like get through it and like do
you enjoy it like it it's it's still one
of those games where you can find a
guild or clan to join to do the raid but
it's definitely not as fun when you're
not doing with people you know part of
the reason why I loved wow so much r
rating before was because you get on
with your you know 810 friends whatever
it was and then you guys would kind of
like have a little mini social gathering
but still buy the game and so when I was
doing the raid with you know like a
pickup group or something it was just
really kind of hard to get through it
and yes I can't do this and actually I
actually thought even the old like just
lfg stuff was fun because you kind of
have to go meet each other and like make
sauce each other Adwords and when they
added in the like just looking for a
party like immediate like the yeah the
dungeon TTYL dungeon finder thing it
kind of took that bit of social aspect
of it as well yeah no more no more like
direct message of like I'm a warrior 60
yes wearing this I am a 45 pounds but
I'm SPECT for the
you don't need but the thing is though
at the end of the day even if while subs
are down to five million it's going to
spike back up to like seven probably so
this is the thing right I was talking to
the to the guys at Gamescom and one of
the things I was talking about was that
peeking and volleying because obviously
they if they reached up to 10 million it
dropped down what they're seeing is that
it's the highs are getting higher but
the loads are getting lower and they
getting faster so there the more
expansion packs or the later expansion
packs are having more people but a
faster fall off or at least that's what
they were sort of agreeing on and the
reason they were saying that is because
they've got an aging demographic that
they reckon is quicker to drop off and
maybe go play something else and then
they're getting a lot of those people
back like people are almost saying oh
that's cool I'll come back when the next
to pack expansion pack comes we feel
like what we're seeing we've never
gotten back up to 15 million like those
Peaks are still in the middle of the
last high range oh yeah like that high
of over 15 million and then down to 10
million and then own back up to 12
million down to 9 million and it just
keeps its slowly working down like the
thing that's going to change that is
when it goes free-to-play head at this
point it has to be when it's free to
play and not is it going to go
free-to-play do you think if it goes
free-to-play because one of the things
that I think might happen is that
whenever they are ready for that to go
free-to-play is when Blizzard launched
their new MMO I'm not saying that that's
not going to be the case like we still I
could see this being even two years out
three years out but I think it has to
happen eventually and then that's when
they're gonna but I mean are they gonna
do another is there is there room for
another world of warcraft type MMO like
thinking about this expansion and how
much time we've invested like how many
how much these subs have gone down no
one's ever been able to replicate what
World of Warcraft is done and what that
both what that means to us except maybe
in terms of destiny can they even match
that again with a massively multiplayer
online game well how is why I'm still
retaining it because it's not like there
wasn't like Guild Wars came out and
everyone thought all and you did see
that initial like MMO people are so
transient like they move from one game
to another all the time we saw people to
go to guild wars and go to go we're
still come back we saw people go to Old
Republic and come back but like even if
their numbers are only around the you
know 56 million range
that's a lot of people so you can keep
them hook to get them a noose pageant
bag surely the one to do it again yeah
it's like this huge nostalgic feeling
it's all the time you invested in your
characters it's it's all of that it's in
your head like I spent so much time
playing this game here are all ten of my
characters or whatever I have like the
few friends that I still play with
Yallah top shape and play guild wars 2
or let's hop ship and play wildstar
because everyone's trying to find the
wow killer I hate using that term
because everyone uses that term but I
always looked at it as wow will never
die until Blizzard decides to kill it
off and we'll make a game that kills it
off right and so those games just don't
have the hook because everyone has this
thing where they compared to wow and
when they get to some point in that new
game that they try it's like oh man but
you know what wild is better than this
and then they start doing that and then
that's when the drop-off happens and
then they go back to wow yeah and then
everyone like you said they they'll play
they stopped because they get tired of
Wow or whatever and then it's like oh
new expansion I'm all-in watch blizzcon
is gonna have the effect it grabs every
one every time it was the craziest thing
for me was like III destiny taken King
it hooked like three or four people in
the office back in that I don't even see
really playing at all and they're all
like oh yeah I'm totally in so like
obviously Activision is doing something
like right with marketing or some people
always have that thing where they want
to go back to the character they've made
but it doesn't happen a lot of other
MMOs like people you'll max at a
character in the Old Republic or and get
any of those games and it it doesn't
have that same hook but like what is it
just is there something about the world
that they've made is it something about
that is it the time is it the fact that
we playing playing this game for over a
decade like what do you think it is
about World of Warcraft specifically
gets people coming back for me that's
what it is it's just that I've played it
for so long that it's that I both have
memories of having played with my
friends that I mean the first MMO that I
really got into was final fantasy 11 mmm
and and that never drew me like that for
me and playing with my friends it was so
so much of a slog in that world warcraft
came along it's like this is what i
wanted like everyone saying it's for
babies but it's fun it's so accessible
and like all every all my other friends
are playing it and like I still have
those good memories and I still want to
get them back when there's a new
expansion that comes out even if it
doesn't quite capture it even if it only
captures it for a week or a month these
are the last time
Thanks yeah cuz everyone every was like
oh yeah let's get back into it and then
like you have your five friends or
something that you kind of play with
then you're like alright sweet and then
y'all level up and then you do a couple
dungeons and then you see one guy stop
then you see the next guy stop then you
see the next guy start and then lo and
behold I'm the one dude sitting in like
how by myself like oh yeah and Barnes
Chuck no I realized why I don't normally
agree to this and I feel like I got
suckered by my friends but it's like
that mini camaraderie and the netting
fact of life oh yeah like when the
expansion comes out you get to
experience something slightly nuin wow
that you didn't get to before and that's
like but you also said this how you
feeling yeah like oh yeah you get you
know so you get a little bit of both
I've this thing where I go back and I
almost go back and not to even play the
new stuff but it's like when I go back
and visit my hometown and I like I just
walk into the grounds of my old school
like just to see what they've changed
you know like oh I remember look around
that's where I you know that's where I
did that that's where I scored that goal
and that's right bought those drugs off
that guy and then oh look they painted
it I'm really only by much different
look is that's different like oh look
there's some kid buying drugs over there
that little massage you feeling I last
question for you guys I just enabled
will you go back and play I mean ollie I
like I no matter what i love the limited
editions like is embarrassing is I know
my them all I have all of them like my
shelf every Gotham they look so good on
the Shelf like they just looked like
next to my books I don't mention him off
showing them up when girl comes over
looks in my book shows like I look at
all the books and some wild things you
don't even know the world of warcraft
those are classy video you can watch it
what's your / played haha no one's ever
said airtight will you go back and play
Legion um I won't unless it's for work
you want liar that's against your hair
can empathize with I I did make a strong
stand at one point I didn't play miss
append area I played a little bit of
Cataclysm because my friends really
pushed I was great that was the ultimate
going back and see how messed up your
school is cuz it was just like oh I'm
gonna go to place I didn't give a [ __ ]
about play the first time just as oh
look a Thousand Needles it's all flooded
and [ __ ] was great I hope not felicity
alright and let us know what you think
about Legion and whether or not you're
going to go back and play when it comes
out sometime next year we're public
founded at blizzcon
you